so welcome to the service Institute my
name's Peter Bartlett an incentive
director and welcome to the second
workshop in the Jambo program this
semester on bridging continuous industry
operate nature so I want to start with a
big thank you to the organizers Alex and
Oni who is the main organizer Miriam
Faizal Alexander my dream or in so rakia
been wrecked been to introduce some
workshop in just a moment but I want to
say a few words about logistics so first
of all we're very proud of the
facilities here and killing the
beautiful auditorium and and we ask you
to please to not bring tea coffee water
but please leave it outside we've got an
overflow room doesn't look like we need
it right now but on the far side of the
building one one six there's going to be
live-streaming to the screen in there of
the of all the talks of the auditorium
is fall during the week please go over
there as you've seen we have tea coffee
snacks they'll be there in the afternoon
lunch
your own but there's a list of options
on the table outside or you can follow a
local or there are lockers outside for
the use of bunch time also if you want
those four wireless access if you have
made your own from your institution you
can not dedicate them so all the talks
are going to be live streamed on YouTube
and then archive got a YouTube channel
the videographer I mean far is here to
help
he's also assisting the speakers with
hooking up computers for the chairs of
sessions we're able to take questions
remotely via Twitter so we have a
Twitter handle si lot and so if you're
chairing a session at question time it'd
be good if you could remind the remote
viewers of the possibility of ask your
questions via Twitter of the organizers
have arranged over half time with a
stream to be monitored so a big thank
you also to the people that did all the
local side of things so else to Sinclair
the outgoing associate director here
this morning
and the events coordinators Andrew Jenn
and Kevin hung is over here so if you
have any questions about anything please
ask Andrew or Kevin so now we'll
introduce bed rec to tell us about the
workshop all right I drew the short
straw so I get to get the intro
welcome I've been saying throughout this
semester that you know we're talking
about bridging the gap between
continuous and discrete optimization I'm
just gonna say it again because I liked
it like saying it but I think that the
biggest gap in optimization is not
between discrete and continuous but
between those who put numerical
experiments in their papers and those
who don't I feel like we have the
biggest diversity of folks are both
camps today they're perfect for this
workshop so this would be good we'll see
how many people have plots in their
slots I'll be the distinguished
literature here so what are we talking
about hitter like what algorithms are
not entered in I think that's actually a
good question and pence we have a very
heterogeneous group and at the end of
the day almost everything this could be
cast in some way as area and that means
almost nothing so what exactly are we
talking about so I think there are four
main themes that we're going to try to
cover that are kind of I think we've
made consider hot topics right now in
optimization today we'll be talking
about using continuous methods for
discrete problems which is something
that in the world of theoretical
computer science has kind of like we
have a receive to come back to many many
times right so now it's again I think in
particular we'll be talking a lot about
tier point methods and fast learner
system sauce our second theme is just a
large-scale optimization in general kind
of what the frontiers and that space are
talking about all sorts of new different
kinds of ways that we compute and on
different kinds of data that we computed
on the third theme is on non convex
optimization which or these iterative
methods for non convex optimization
because non convex optimization as we
know it's basically everything so we're
gonna supposed to focus on very specific
case here about iterative schemes that
actually can provably solve not the best
problems and then finally we're going to
have a session on using methods from
sketching for optimization again taking
out kind of the opposite today's thing
taking goals from discrete optimization
and then applying them back to me
so starting off the workshop will be oh
and I guess that this is actually an
important thing to say
Everett we're gonna have somewhat survey
talks kind of to start off every theme
Alexander's gonna give that exactly
right I think all of us some kind of
signed up for this so good this is
Alexander Alex you do one I'm gonna do
one I think all of us you signed up for
this so the two phrases wrong kind of
realize that this is actually much
harder than to disturb a the current
state of affairs that we've gotten
anticipated but shouldn't keep it
entertaining finally we have two special
sessions that we're gonna try out one is
the open problem session will be
Wednesday at 4:00 which should this be a
heated discussion amongst all of us I'm
sure and the second we're gonna have
lightning talks which actually was tried
at one of the workshops last semester on
machine learning I thought was very
successful so we're gonna if you want to
give a lightning talk and I would
strongly encourage you if you're not
giving a full talk please come give a
light to talk to your boss a cool stuff
like I'd love to hear about some of the
work their process is doing lately so
thank you so if you are interested in
giving a lightning talk email me with a
title and put in the subject it'll all
cast lightning talk and I don't care
what else in the subject that will that
will be a good filter so all caps
lightning talk and we're hoping that
we're gonna preference our fellows and
then our long term participants but this
is open to everyone this is space allows
and they're gonna be no more than 10
minutes and we might make them slightly
less than 10 minutes depending on demand
okay so please email me and I will send
out periodic providers throughout the
day lightning talk my email
okay so without further ado and hand the
floor over to Alexander
okay welcome everyone so as Ben said
what we signed up for was to give you
the survey of the field but then I must
say well I have to make an admission so
the admission is that I was thinking for
a long time what this talk should be
about and I had this kind of vague
vision of like I will like server you
know how we start from like using convex
relaxations to solve like discrete
problems then we realize that actually
you can even solve them like some of the
problems like packing and covering you
can solve fast iterative methods and
then we go through the full circle that
now for some of the problems like max
floor matchings actually the best way to
to get something done is to cast this as
an LP and just hold the test okay so
that was the plan and then I realized
that yeah this is much harder to do than
it initially initially feels like more
importantly I got totally bored like
essentially I think at this moment you
know but given like the mix of like
given that this is what this semester is
about and we have all this Xpress here
and we had a bootcamp and also we had
them we had actually a workshop and not
so far ago I realized that I would just
bore everyone to death and more
importantly myself so what I decided to
do I was headed to do like bait and
switch so essentially what I want to do
I will talk about something different
yeah so essentially okay so that so what
I want to talk about is about our recent
result but somehow I think very nicely
shows how can you take a program that is
not discrete is actually problem from
from scientific computing but you can
very nicely view it and you like sort of
unified the view of this problem by just
you know applying coded optimization to
it okay
and somehow first of all I really like
this result and you know and so this is
a talk I'm not bored to give so that's I
guess that's something that that's one
even further choice there's also
unfortunately much more sad reason for
that so you know and some of you might
know
recently a Michael Cohen who was like a
brilliant person and I would say the
spirit of above the fear group at MIT
and also of this Simon's here so anyone
who have seen it you know he was
everywhere he was talking to everyone
and she was like exactly exemplifying
this kind of spirit of thus learning
everything and trying to do everything
and last but not least my student so
this is actually one of the last works I
I work with him and I thought that this
would be just fitting to somehow talk a
bit about that okay so I'm not sure I'm
ready to talk about Michael but you know
at least I think I can I can talk about
the result he will enjoy except he
wouldn't because she said okay we
already done it so you know why to talk
about that but yeah so and yeah so the
way I want to do it actually I want to
do it on a white board for a variety of
reasons first of all because I didn't
prepare slides but you know second of
all actually I think this is a table
that works better on on a whiteboard so
let's just do that and then can punish
me later well for reneging of on the on
the commitment to okay that doesn't work
well so I would leave it for a moment
and then we ended okay
so since this is the result with well
Michael myself Dimitri's its tsipras
agile Vlad oh and it will appear in this
upcoming Fox and you know one thing I
want to mention is actually there is a
independent result by so I get the names
all the names right so hey Alan Zoo
okay Lee only Viera Rivera sorry and
wearisome also appears in the upcoming
Fox which you know is actually very
similar in spirit it gets a bit
different bounce but you know this
period is the same okay so what yeah so
what I want to talk about it I want to
talk to about you know very classic
questions in scientific computing called
matrix scaling and Mattocks balancing so
in a matrix balancing we have we are
given a matrix a which is square okay so
we are given a square matrix a with all
with all entries and non-negative and
then what you want to do is we want to
find so given given a find we want to
find matrix X which is a diagonal matrix
such that if I look at the product of X
a X inverse okay so essentially I just
multiply second this is diagonal matrix
it just has one entry on diagonal and
zeros everywhere else okay if I look at
that what I would like this matrix to be
I would like it to be balanced what it
means is that if I look at any row of
this matrix okay and they sum up the you
know and they sum up all the entries in
it and they look at the corresponding
column of the matrix and I want to sum
up all the entries in there I would like
the sound to be equal to each other okay
for every column ever also you know a
concise way of writing this is I would
like so if this will be the my matrix M
then I would like M times all ones
vector be equal to M transpose times
okay so so this is this is one problem
in the moment I will tell you why you
might care for this problem the other
problem that I want to consider is
scaling matrix scaling in which again
you are given an input matrix a okay
but also you are given two vectors R and
C and what you want is you want to find
out not one but actually two two
matrices x and y that are diagonal okay
and what you want to do is you want to
do a look at the matrix X a Y okay and
what you like what you would like
well now you would like to essentially
look at the corresponding row and you
would like to sum of the row entries to
be equal to whatever the vector R is
giving you so essentially like you know
the I throw should be the sum of the
entries in the I throw should be equal
to I and then similar thing is for
columns so essentially this some on the
the sum of the entries in a given column
should should be equal to should be
equal to this whatever given is given by
Delta C okay so now these are the two
problems by the way a you know this is
this might not always be possible
essentially it may not be possible for
all possible Aran's are R and C and a
and the particular one you know very
important special cases as exactly the
case when these vectors are just on ones
vectors and this just corresponds to
scaling the matrix so it's doubly
stochastic okay and you know similarly
here not always such a balancing exists
essentially exist if and only if you
know the corresponding graph is actually
strongly connected but what we will not
worry about these things at all now a
few words sorry these problems were
actually quite heavily studied studied
in the scientific computing literature
actually algorithms for matrix balancing
and matrix Kaling's are implemented in
MATLAB and all the scientific computing
software and somehow one reason why
these are interesting operations to have
is that actually they are very nice they
kill Burnett invariants with respect to
some important a sensitive computing
primitives so in particular one nice
thing about you know the ratio between
the matrix a and the
the balance matrix M is that actually if
we just look at the if you just want to
get the eigenvalues of the matrix a a if
you want to compute the my various
arguments of the mathematics a then this
scaling by X and X minus a and X inverse
does not change the eigen values at all
it changes the eigen vectors but the
eigen values stay the same so what is
nice about this essentially if I have a
matrix a that I would like to compute
its eigen values off but it doesn't have
some you know some properties like maybe
it doesn't have nice properties from the
point of view of numerical point of view
you might think of rescaling it to get
an equivalent matrix M whose equivalent
for the task that you are actually
trying to solve but it might be nicer
here okay and similarly here scaling
actually is nice with respect to solving
a linear system in a ok so if this is M
okay so essentially if I have a linear
system a let's call it Z equal B what I
can do is I can on one hand just
multiply both sides by X from the left
okay but then also secondary parameter
is Z to make it just Y times some you
know s okay since Y is all is that
they're gonna match the positive entries
this representation doesn't lose
anything and now I actually need just to
solve a linear system in yet once I had
one after solve the system I can recover
what the solutions if should be very
easy and again the hope is that the the
numerical properties of this matrix M
actually will end up being nicer than
the potential properties of the matrix a
ok so this is sort of the fury now you
know the good thing about bell play is
that even if you get you know if you get
called into giving a seminar about some
of the results there then there are some
like you know very like in the first row
there are some you know very very old
professor emerita
it turns out the doctor these are the
guys who invented this thing and then
they tell you that actually they don't
really want to solve this problem like
the reason why they solve this problem
is that because they sort of like what
they care about is the algorithm that
solve this problem as opposed to the
solution itself so actually it turns out
that you know all that the way they
wanted they wanted certain property
that you get when you like a natural
algorithm for solving this is applied
and not actually they never really want
to solve this problem itself so this is
like how science works but you know
anyway that's a that's definitely
something you know that's definitely you
know something to keep in mind that
somehow you might be you know if you are
not from the field you might be mistaken
about like how much importance there is
to actual solution as opposed to some
other things and still there is an i
care about these problems is that first
of all they actually can be used to
compute matchings which is the thing
that I actually care about and more
importantly I think they lead to a very
interesting a contingent imitation
primitives and that's what I want to
talk about today okay so now what I will
do in the rest of the talk I will forget
about matrix scaling I would just focus
on the matrix balancing but everything I
say essentially transfers over to metric
scaling as well and as far as I know it
is actually the first time when both of
these problems are actually treated in
uniform manner usually there was a line
of work on these problems and the line
of work on these problems and you know
and that's and that's where we're in our
story that's how think I think stood
okay so let me let me talk about this so
what is the idea so we have this problem
let's say we want to solve this matrix
balancing problem and now you know how
do we go about it well I already sort of
spoil the surprise and you know the
surprise says that essentially we will
try to use continuous optimization to
get the solution okay so how can we use
continued optimization to get solution
well there's only one thing that
conducive mutation can do it can just
minimize function like minimize some
functions so essentially what I want to
do I want first to encode this problem
of matrix balancing is just an
immunization question like I want just I
wanted to correspond to minimizing of
some of the you know of some of the of
some of the things okay by the way one
thing I should mention is that actually
what are the results that we get but I
will get it to the later on I also did
not discuss these notice the previous
work which actually is quite extensive
so let me just say that the current best
know our roots for the problem is that
for matrix scaling is just roughy and to
the for if I want to get like epsilon
close approximation to the problem then
actually attached to spend time as
atrophy em to default and this is a
result due to colon 3 and calcium I
think Colin Terry Collins re re cashier
from from 96 ok for matrix balancing
there's actually as a couple of relevant
works so there is actually Shulman and
Sinclair had one result it's in 2015 and
they got the running time of n cube log
1 over epsilon and then also recently
there was a very nice world that
actually inspired us to look at this
problem by Ostrovsky ski Rabbani and and
use Fe this is 17 which essentially
showed algorithm actually nearly linear
except they depend for a polynomial one
over epsilon as opposed to
logarithmically so they get a time of
like something like M plus
so that's all I would say both about
about this work and what we get actually
is you know what we get is actually we
get the time that is roughly M times log
of Q like K of X star log soldiers this
is just like the bit complexity of the
problem
so essentially what they are they are
essentially linear like rank time is
linear times the log of the what I call
the condition number of the optimal
matrix X so essentially AK if X star is
the optimal solution that actually gives
exact balancing I want to look at this
condition number namely the safety ratio
of the largest to the smallest entry
here what causes the diagonal matrix so
essentially we are you know we depended
logarithmically on that and we just add
in a linear needed nearly like the
linear time on top of it okay so this
might sound like something being small
except it actually isn't so
unfortunately the condition numbers of
this optimal solution maybe even
exponential so essentially this just in
the worst case it's well it's never more
than n so essentially in the worst case
this is the running times M n log 1 over
Epsilon but so for special cases for
instance in the case where the matrix a
has all the entries positive it's
actually this thing is logarithmic so so
essentially then you can do linear
nearby ok
inside the result yes yes but yes so
essentially it was except
sorry it's a bit harder ok I didn't want
to get into that I think when you have
logarithmic like essentially a case for
anything is not exactly true but you
know for any LP things this doesn't
matter
except for L infinity which you know ok
again problem with experts in the
audience that actually they know what I
or what I'm talking about and they can
call me out like the point is that here
this is a bit harder version of the
problem they are all essentially
equivalent like I think you know I think
as long as you're in the regime of local
number epsilon here when you're in the
regime of polynomial epsilon this is
actually has to be very careful how you
define your error but in this individual
in the general regime it doesn't matter
that much yes we have bad examples
window look I will talk about that yes
so essentially it's actually this bount
is essentially tight for our approach
okay it doesn't mean that it is just
it's I will explain exactly there is a
very good way of explaining what are the
limits of our approach okay so so
essentially so here so all all we now is
just to set up a function that actually
captures like minimization of which
captures you know what you want to do
and the function actually is very easy
so essentially so the way I will work
now is I will just repair matter is the
problem and I will think that my matrix
actually is well the rebalance matrix is
corresponds to like I don't keep exactly
the matrix X I actually keep just you
know the logarithms of the entries okay
so this is like X 2 minus X essentially
so so you know my like each entry is
just like you know X now okay so maybe I
should change it to maybe I should call
it y
sorry so essentially what I have is that
my you know like I want still tiny okay
good so that's great
good so essentially I want just my
matrix a my balancing matrix to
correspond to X 2 dou Y okay so
essentially I'm just keeping you know
they will just make all the expression
easier if I think about the lots of them
as opposed to like so them directly and
then the function that I'm trying to
minimize is just the sum over all
entries the IJ entry times e2 y i- YJ
okay so this is the function
I just want to minimize and and I claim
that minimizing this fraction
corresponds to solving to the ballasting
problem why well in conduce elimination
there is only one reason why and you
know the reason is just to look at the
gradient of this function okay and when
you look at the gradient of this
function what you realize is that very
conveniently that essentially you know
it corresponds to the just the
difference of two vectors are like RM
and CM when RM is just the where RM is
just the row sums of the of this
rescaled matrix so this is like you know
X Y a X minus y ok and C are the column
sums okay so clearly this is 0 if this
is 0 this immediately implies that the
column sums are corresponding to our
equal to the to the row sum so clearly
this individual and will mean that the
matrix is balanced ok
so far so good yeah they're a sun-
otherwise I would be in a world of
trouble right because exactly if you
look at this function so clearly finding
a critical point of this of this
function gives you the solution now the
question is you know how do you minimize
this function in particular what it was
I'm sure a Pablo was worried about is
that if this entries are not
non-negative this function is not convex
and then we are in the non convex
optimization regime and when did not let
us get there yet so essentially we are
assuming here that all the entries are
non-negative so this function is convex
and then essentially we know that in
principle we can by you know applying
gradient descent we can eventually get
to a good solution okay and in a sense
the result of so scarab onion juice EFI
can be viewed as a gradient descent
scheme applied to a function like that
okay however we want to get logarithmic
depends never a restaurant so just
applying gradient descent to this and
just like waiting for it to converge
might not be like it does not give us
fast left of edges so you know you would
like to use some stronger tool to
actually minimize this function and what
is the stronger tool in continuous
optimization that you usually use in
such cases well essentially when you
don't have strong convexity which you in
principle you don't have to hear well
what you do is essentially use
second-order methods okay
so essentially you use newton method
so what does Newton's method corresponds
to essentially the way Newton's method
works is that it looks at the you know
approximation of the of the function
around a given point and actually looks
at not only the like Taylor
approximation so this is f of Y plus the
gradient of F at Y times Delta so this
is like the first other approximation
but it actually looks at also at the
second order approximation of this
function which involves the Hessian of
it of the of this function okay and then
there are there are then there are
further terms and what it says it says
okay I will view my function as this you
know as this quadratic approximation and
I will just try to directly minimize
this so I will get I will try to go in
the direction of the you know of the
that corresponds to minimizing this
quadratic proxy for my function okay so
when you when you work it out the
direction that you actually will end up
going is you know the Delta Newton is
essentially minus the inverse of the
Hessian times the gradient
and that's how they that's how the
neutrons that's helping it with its work
now if you remember from the bootcamp
you realize that you know well you know
so you know one thing about Newton's
methods that clearly it's convergence
you would expect to be superior to the
convergence of the gradient schemes
because it's using better approximation
except there is a problem because
actually you know the problem is that
somehow we might be overfitting to this
local to this local approximation of the
function
so essentially Newton's method works
only well like what works well only if
what happens is that essentially we only
use it in the neighborhood of Y in which
the Hessian does not change too much
okay so essentially Newton's method is
good what's good
only you know as long as whatever point
y prime we go to okay well the Hessian
at that point is roughly similar to the
Hessian at the point we started okay so
only then we can actually say something
intelligent about you know how good the
approximation is and how much progress
we make okay and the usual struggle with
applying Newton's method is exactly
figuring out you know what is this
neighborhood of you know where the
Hessian actually you know would work
okay so and that's exactly the question
that will motivate our algorithm here
okay so we now already know what is the
function theorem to minimize we know
what this is gradient so now let's take
a look at what is its passion so the
Hessian of this function is actually
something very simple is essentially the
diagonal matrix that you get by taking
the vectors corresponding to the row
sums and the column sums and just like
making regular matrix out of it and then
you subtract from this
then you subtract from this and matrix M
plus M transpose okay this is the
Hessian okay so yeah so now we have one
of the Hessian and now we can try to
understand I can try to understand how
quickly it changes as we actually vary Y
okay so if I fix you if I take a
snapshot of the Hessian at Y and then I
start moving you know the question is
now how quickly does the corresponding
matrix actually become very different to
the matrix I started with okay and when
you think about it for a moment
then what you will realize that
essentially you know the one sufficient
condition is that you know as long as my
new point a Y prime is at most 1/2 away
in L infinity norm so essentially as
long as I didn't change any of this
individual entries by more than 1/2 but
essentially what happens is a well then
then what happens is that you know the
corresponding entry X I which is you
know e to the Y I is essentially well
multiplicatively approximated is within
a quickly the multiplicative error of
1/2 of the you know of the new entry
which is x i prime and this turns out to
be sufficient to essentially show that
this you know that this that these two
haitians
are actually closed okay so essentially
the key inset here that says is that you
know I can if I want to minimize if I
want to minimize my function f by
looking at this quadratic approximation
and trying to go in direction in which
this approximation tells me then this
will work as long as I will know as long
as it will never move than more than one
half in elephant you know norm away from
the point where I started okay so
essentially in this radius like in this
if this is my function this is my point
y then you know there is this box of a
radius of radius one around my point
necessarily as long as I just minimize
the function you know in this box and as
long as I will find the minimizer of
this function in this box then I can
actually quantify how much progress I
make okay once I'm outside of this box
essentially this approximation like we
lose any control over this approximation
and we don't know what happens but you
know as long as we just minimize it
inside this box we are fine we are
making progress okay so what it
motivates is well this exactly motivates
the algorithm for the for this forcing
of this problem for solving of this
problem
so how does this algorithm or well
essentially what we do is you know
exactly it's exactly what I said
so we just take we just start with some
initial point
we just start from some initial point
you know y0 okay and now in each you
know for each i from one up to however
long we want to run this procedure yes
it just half it's really actually
because they essentially remember that
the y's are exponents in like like like
the surgery XS are just exponents of y
so as long as i just add up to plus
minus 1/2 this will this will change by
at most a factor of two one way or the
other and that's just enough to get you
know the statement that this you know
that this new hacchyan is actually
within there like spectrally
approximated by the old-fashioned up to
a factor of two as well okay so what is
the algorithm oh well what we do is that
essentially we like well to get our
point like yi1 sorry get point why i
what we do is essentially we just find a
minimizer so this is arc mean overall
wise prime such that they are in this
box around the previous solution okay so
essentially we ensure that we only look
around the solutions that are within you
one half in L infinity norm from the
point where we started of this quadratic
approximation here okay let's call it f
let's call it FY of y prime okay
F Y okay so essentially what we are
doing is essentially we're always you
know we look at the current point we
look at this local quadratic
approximation around this point and then
we find the minimizer of this aquatic
approximation subject to staying in this
box around our initial point okay so
just for the record this is not how the
original original that works because in
tomato just cares about l2 and
essentially just like essentially it you
know it just always works in the
direction here there is in general no
closed-form solution for this problem
okay this is just an optimization
problem that you have to solve and you
know we just call this primitive a box
constraint constraint Newton's method
and now we know we just want to apply it
to our function so clearly again you
don't go to Eliza but this is not heart
is a saying that we'll each time we
maintain this condition as long as you
set in the box this actually makes a lot
of progress like essentially you know we
well you can quantify how much progress
you always advance it to make so
essentially the the theorem that you get
out of this is that you can like this
method will converge to an absolute
approximate solution in number of
iterations number of iterations that is
at most you know all of what log 1 over
epsilon or like he'll the bit complexity
of the problem over epsilon now but
there is a there is a quantifier here
and essentially this is at most R
infinity where our infinity is just the
radius of the problem in alpha t norm so
essentially R infinity is just you know
the okay so I'm lying a bit now but I
will explain how I'm lying in a moment
so this is essentially the nfinity
distance of my initial point and the
optimal point okay so notice by the way
okay so the way I'm lying that actually
you don't only need to bound this radius
for the initial point you actually need
to bound it over the level set in which
the initial point lies but let's just
not worry about this you just have to do
some extra work so to go around it but
this is the
this is the heart of it but the
important part is that actually this
shows that actually this bound is
essentially close to optimal for the
setting why well because I notice that
in each step we we always insist by
moving by at most 1/2 in Le 15 or so
just to get from y 0 to whatever Y star
is I just need to spend this many steps
roughly okay and then we are just adding
you know a logarithm of another epsilon
top of that we are in actually we can
really actually converge to this close
to optimal solution okay so this is the
statement and it looks like we are
almost done except we are not okay
because you know this gives an algorithm
but then there is one thing that is
still missing essentially we don't know
how to solve this optimization problem
is like an iteration we have to solve
this this is this optimization problem
okay so now let's look at what this
activity optimization problem is well
essentially this optimization problem
corresponds to
response to minimizing a quadratic
function yes because it's a quadratic
function over a over a box right so you
know at the essentially in the end the
primitive that we like well the thing
that we need to solve is essentially
minimize over some Z that is supposed to
lie in about any unit in a unit in the
unit infinity box or and what we want to
minimize is you know a function which is
just a let's go BG plus some little B
times it's okay say we are trying to
minimize an arbitrary quadratic function
with B being from negative for the
columns is non-negative over a box so
the funny thing is how to how to do it
quickly so notice that if I didn't have
this constraint okay
then actually essentially I will just
minimize over the this quadratic form
then we exactly know how to solve this
problem this problem is equivalent to
the solving a linear system in a linear
system a linear system in in in the
capital B okay that's exactly what the
solution is okay in particular that's
how you actually solve the systems in
practice so that's good because actually
you know the well the matrix we are
using here is actually the Hessian of
our function and Oh as I conveniently
erase now but if you look at the Hessian
it turns out that not only it's actually
a like positive semi definite so the
function is convex but actually is also
is also an SD B matrix essentially it's
just you know it will essentially the
symmetric diagonally dominant dominated
matrix and what it says is that actually
for SDI or for SD d vertices we know how
to solve such linear systems very very
efficiently so we can actually do it in
millionaire time okay so that's great
because now we have all the machinery
for solving this linear system except
what we are doing here is more general
than that because we also have this this
constraint and now it's no longer it's
no longer just like I solve equal in
your systems so how it could be so equal
in your system as long as we optimize
social never
violate this constraint but you know in
general this might not be the case so
somehow we have to take into advantage
this infinity constraints so no long
story short what we say is it actually
still even though this a generalization
of the like kind of SD solving we can
leave the tools of like the approaches
of sdd of the dissolving to the setting
in particular the solver that we use is
the solver due to Li Peng and Spielman
60 which you know like basically what
works very nicely just essentially what
it does it just looks at the matrix it
iteratively figures out sort of the sub
matrices of this big matrix that are
easy to solve it just solves them
recursively and then use a stroke
complement to recurse on the rest okay
and it turns out that even though this
was something designed just for solving
the problem without this thing it
essentially solved this problem as well
okay so technically what happens is we
have to we get a solution that violates
this bound this this you know this bound
of reduced one but the value evaluated
at most by a factor of logarithmic which
is completely fine with us we just take
a smaller step size and essentially we
just get an another factor of Logan in
running time and everything works but
then but me sorry for which word for for
for this problem or for or for the
subproblems yeah then it's actually like
I think the struck solving case or is
there just resolving in your system
right is it no it's not yeah it's not
yes I would suspect but it's not helpful
for us so it's not helpful because
essentially okay I guess
well so the point is that a linphea like
sort of like taking a step in the in the
you know in the unit wealth FEG box is
actually much larger than an l2 ball and
as far as you remember again I will not
give it is do you do know I minor
my intuition is I would need to check it
thing is that actually when you are
constrained to only take a steps in L to
ball you will actually need many many
more steps no concessions they feel like
they like L to radius will be large much
larger to Delhi Fatima LVT reduce well I
just make the problem much easier so and
you could still use this because yeah
well okay so you just add you know the
Lagrange multiplier for that and this
everything is nice yes so so I know that
it's easier except we really need we
really need a really theater here so
when when I said sorry just when I said
that this is like something is just like
no we just add Lagrangian term and it's
still like solving your sister yeah okay
so of course yes so so definitely like
always you know we know that the the the
the the L infinity the radius is at more
it's at most like square square root of
M smaller so this is defiantly like so
you know why doing what you propose we
in the worst case lose square root of M
except I have a feeling I'm pretty sure
like there are examples where actually
you really pay the squares of a message
you know this you really you really like
pay for this worse performance so if you
can get you know the same thing for this
L infinity but the problem that's what
you want to get okay and somehow yeah
and as you see this actually act
authorizes so special like the only
thing we really needed from the from the
function f is essentially that like for
this general approach to work is that
this you know this function has this
property that the Hessian is stable as
long as we move by one in your life you
know so the point is that actually you
can solve this problem with just
logarithmic number of of s DD calls so
this is not obvious and you know you
have to work for it but in the end like
this particular solver is particularly
nice for that that actually you can
adjust it and get and get the right peak
it was like so hot the point here is
that this thing always works like a very
well condition problem and then just you
know enforcing the self into constraints
there is sort of easy okay but yes this
is not obvious that this is you know
essentially you can get it at the same
price lakh as just if there was alt wand
let's ask a little to go like it a
little silly that's a great question I
don't know that's a good again you can
definitely intercept or you can
approximate you know what you need from
this L infinity ball by a flip side so
possibly this could be something that
that worked but we didn't try it and I
will just if I have time I will just
touch briefly about you know what are
the kind of what is the barrier here and
this might also I answer this question
okay
so essentially that's that's almost it I
just described to you all the main
ingredients of the of the of the
algorithm what I want to finish with is
actually I want to give you a bit
different perspective and the problem
that we are solving here okay
so essentially so far we just thought
about okay we are trying to find this
matrix balancing and then this
corresponds to minimizes this function
but there's actually a very nice
internal and some how to solve it
efficiently we need to use this
generalization of the sed systems like
of the AC system solving so well turns
out that there is some very nice kind of
way of looking at the problem that
somehow makes a nice analogy of what
happened in the context of illogical
flocks and the importance of solving
there so essentially what happens is
that
what happens is that actually you can
view like instead of looking at the math
expand a sink or momentum of this
function you can view just a look at the
problem that I will call nonlinear
nonlinear flow problem so think of it as
a generalization of the electrical flow
problem in which you just hear a flow
problem I just give you the man's right
and then I want you to find you know to
find voltages that you know induce an
electrical flow via Ohm's law that says
faces the months
right that's what L see a flow problem
is and we know that essentially this
corresponds to just solving classes like
this voltages correspond to just solving
a linear system the laplacian okay
that's exactly what the extra cash flow
problem is so this is the electrical
now what we want to consider is so here
the data flow you know the crucial thing
here is that is the Ohm's law which says
that essentially my flow induced on the
edge I J is exactly given by you know
the difference of the potentials between
X X I like between I and J well divided
by the resistance this is how we go from
the voltage space to the floor space in
the electrical flow question okay and
then we know that you know if you want
to find the right voltage that induce
the flow of the Mundy
that's what we need to do now imagine
internalization of this which I call
exponential Ohm's law which the flow
that you actually get on the edge I J is
not just linear in the differences it's
actually exponentially in the difference
okay so it's just equal to let's call
this you know 1 over R IJ of
exponentiation of X I minus XJ okay this
is still a well-defined problem in which
you now I want you to find voltages X I
and X J such that you know if I look at
the flow induced by this you know by
this by this by this voltages according
to the exponential law I want to satisfy
the demands okay so you can view that
there is some operator like a like L
that takes the voltages and gives you
the flows and you would like it to be
exactly you know satisfy the demands
that you want it okay well the problem
here is that now this operator is no
longer linear its exponential and you
the question is no how do you solve such
a question well it turns out that
solving the balancing problem is exactly
essentially equivalent to this question
raised essentially that all like if I
want to solve a balancing problem then
okay so essentially like the balancing
problem
it corresponds to taking solving this
equation LX equal all 0 so you just want
to find the flow that has you know zero
demons okay well in which we know your
resistance you know one over resistance
is exactly equal to doing of
corresponding entry in your matrix so
here you think of your matrix is
specifying a graph with resistances and
then you want to find you know the flow
that has zero that has zero demands with
respect to this exponential arms law as
opposed to linear Ohm's law what is that
platform Iran's law if I want the months
to be 0 then the answer 0 is always
correct she actually is actually quite
non-trivial to compute it you actually
need to you know to use this algorithm
machinery to just fold that but I think
this is like a very nice way very nice
analogy to know what happened to Attica
flow through the different flows you
know they correspond to linear linear um
slow and then sonic sed systems becomes
like the crucial primitives to just
solve it otherwise here you know for the
exponential um slow this corresponds to
matrix balancing and also you can you
can encode matrix scaling it as well and
and then you know the primitive that
becomes is still an SD disorder except
now you have to solve this more general
version of it okay so the last thing I
just want to say is that you know the
bands that we had here you know the
question is you know out are this band
optimal well clearly they are optimal
for our approach because you know the
way we bound things you never can move
by more than 1/2 in an 15 or so you
always would have this barrier of this
add infinity by infinity infinity radius
except what we do feel is that this is
answering the question you see that
actually there should be a way like
somehow you know clearly as long as you
never move more by by 1/2 in L infinity
norm you will be safe like your your
approximation chronic approximation of
the function will always be good but you
know maybe you can sometimes move much
further and still have control over how
this approximation happens so I think
there is something to understand here
it's we don't have a good idea how to
extend it about so this would be the
frontier of it that I find you know very
interesting and I would love to talk to
you if you are
thank you yes that's the theme of
continuous methods for discrete
optimization is there anything to speed
here no nothing I treat it
I'm sorry for wasting your time well you
can encode computing matchings in it so
this is the the connection but honestly
like this is just like it this is not I
wouldn't say this is a very compelling
connection well sync imbalance sync
essentially is you know is just a way to
solve scaling problem in which is just
like Gridley essentially you just what
you do is essentially you what do you do
exactly
you just yes exactly yes so essentially
you either just want to update things so
you so you just get the columns right or
about this can break rows and then you
do rows and this can be problems so
essentially I think you can so I didn't
verify it but my feeling could be that
the sink or balancing would corresponds
to just a gradient descent scheme on
this function I don't know that's a
great question
I don't know yeah it's very simple
method and central it corresponds so so
what I do know is that the Osborne
iteration for matrix balancing can like
with the right people think roll can be
viewed as just struggle innocent on this
thing on the gravity function so I
suspected something similar is true for
sinker balancing but you know but I I
cannot okay yeah you're probably right
yes so you using convexity of F but that
really something strong ways to write
that the log of f is best
yes so somehow doesn't that I mean that
that's at least a classical voyage
conditionally dominant and I know that
you can do yeah that's a great question
I know we like I think we thought about
briefly we couldn't get anything out of
it really okay it doesn't mean that
there is nothing there yeah so making
you how to use that the log of a
function convex improve something that's
like nothing better than we had right to
Michael being able to solve the so
prompt sub problem very exactly I I
don't see any reason why you couldn't be
able to do it we just don't seem to get
any mileage out of it so we didn't
really try so yeah yeah like it's
actually interesting you know what kind
of generalization of realization of this
like the business utilization of La Paz
and solving of this whole thing so
question is how far can you push it into
like what interesting can you find here
okay thank you
[Applause]